[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to my talk, which
apparently my naming joke
was also simultaneously thought
of by Lawrence Moroney, if you
went to his talk two hours ago.
But it's a clever one.
The goal today is to
walk through everything
you need to understand in
order to be able to understand
how JobScheduler works.
Because if you can
know how to choose
between different options of
building a background task,
we'll just build a better app,
which will be really great.
JobScheduler is really
scary, and nobody ever
wants to talk about it,
because if you bring it up
and somebody starts
talking to you,
you probably won't understand
what they're talking about.
And that's hard.
So we're going to go through all
of it, and by the end of this
you're going to walk out of here
ready to name drop JobScheduler
and just really rampant
and advocate for it.
So it will be great.
Why you should listen to me?
I am Joanna Smith, this is a
copy of my bio off the website.
You can read that, or not.
Specifically the things
I've done with Android--
I co-founded the Android
Development Patterns
Initiative.
We have a lot of
videos, me and Ian Lake.
He's right there.
You probably just
watched his talk.
We made the videos and we
have a weekly pro-tip series
of written content and
we have a lot more ideas
coming over the next year.
We're trying to identify--
bust bad behavior
and teach best practices.
Because we have a
lot of developer
outreach on how Android
works, and how APIs work,
and really how
you can implement.
But we don't have anyone
telling you when to implement
or what to choose, or
what the options are.
Or if you have 13
different paths which one's
going to be best for your app.
So we're trying to
tackle that problem.
Watch our videos, let us
know how well we're doing.
And then also, we created the
second course in our Udacity
Android Nanodegree.
So if you're trying
to expand your skills
or just brush up on something
you haven't seen before,
that's a really great resource.
All those course materials
are available online for free.
But if you enroll in the
class and pay the fee,
you also get
instructor guidance.
That's pretty cool.
And then this is just like a fun
fact I like to throw out there,
I started learning Android,
actually in February of 2014.
So I'm very new to this game
compared to a lot of people.
I like to bring that up because
it can seem really intimidating
when you're learning
something new,
and you're trying
to get into it,
and everyone's talking
about all these words
that you don't understand.
And they're reminiscing about
how Gingerbread was so ugly.
And you're like, I don't think
I ever had a Gingerbread phone.
I don't know how to participate
in this conversation.
And it's intimidating, and
this is a hard, hard problem
to solve.
I just want everyone to know,
you don't-- I mean I did this
lesson two years ago, and
I'm giving a talk to you guys
as if I'm an expert.
You can really learn
a lot, really fast
if you just push
yourself and try.
So that being said, let's
try Background Services.
The goal here is we want
to do a bunch of work
off of our main thread.
And because that
main thread, it's
also called the UI thread
for a very good reason,
meaning that it
controls everything
that you can see on the device.
If something starts to go
wrong, and you're still
on your UI thread,
you're user is just going
to see this hideous thing.
Don't be this!
It's ugly, I couldn't even
find a good picture of it,
because nobody wants
to screenshot it.
It's such a horrifying sight.
Right?
And I didn't know
how to make one.
If you show this to your
user, if this comes up,
your user is immediately
giving up on you.
They're leaving the app,
they're not trying again,
they're not going
to try and refresh.
Most likely they won't
open your app again,
and they will probably
even uninstall you.
This is a death warrant, and
you don't want to see this.
But the thing is,
that's what users see.
What it actually
means is that your app
is working really hard,
and it just needs a minute.
And that's what's
really frustrating
because the developer
perspective here
is that you're trying to do work
and you just forgot something.
But the user perspective
is you're the worst ever,
and I hate you.
We're going to
move on, and we're
going to avoid this by moving
something off the main thread.
Work that's going
to hang is going
to make us miss our frame rate,
and we don't want to do that.
So we're going to
just shift it away,
and then it can re-sync
with the later activity
when it's time to
actually update it.
Instead of trying to
pause the current activity
and wait for it.
OK, so that's our goal.
So we don't want to
miss our frame rate,
because we've missed that,
[INAUDIBLE] will just magically
appear and start hating on you.
[LAUGHTER]
So the question is,
where do we start?
And when I say back
on work, all of you
are probably thinking
oh, good, AsyncTask.
And that's not correct.
AsyncTask is actually tied
to activity lifecycle.
And that have its own
advantages and disadvantages.
So I'm going to focus
on work that is entirely
off the main thread and
AsyncTask has its place,
and you can read all
about it on your own.
So let's start with services.
What's a service?
Well, it's complex.
They're hard.
They have a lot of pieces
you have to manage.
Services run in the background.
They're fully apart from any
app activity or fragment,
but that means that
it can keep running,
even when your app isn't.
Which is actually
pretty fantastic.
But because of this,
that means that services
can't affect your UI.
So if you actually want
to show progress dialogue,
because what you're doing is
in response to user initiated
action, you probably do
want your AsyncTask that's
a really great way to do it.
But if you're kicking off
some sort of activity that
only needs to report
back when it's done,
maybe update the
UI then, a service
is going to be great, because it
can send that information back
through other avenues later on.
But, you can update the UI
while you're in a service.
So any results you
have to pass it.
Services are great for things
like syncing with your server.
This is something that's
not usually user initiated,
but you want to back up
all those photos they've
been taking in your app.
That's really
important, but that
doesn't have to happen
exactly at that moment.
That could happen when the
phone is put down or is idle,
or just whenever
there's a chance
and the radio's already on.
The other thing is
that services have
to manage their own lifecycle.
And that can be kind
of intimidating.
Because you have to first figure
out which methods to override.
And then how to override them.
And then what you
want to leave alone.
And then how you call it.
And it's just a lot, which
goes back to my point
that services are complex.
So, that's why we're going to
talk about IntentService, which
does all this work for you.
How nice is that?
So IntentService is a much
easier implementation,
because it will handle
all of its own lifecycle.
You don't have to worry
about starting it, or binding
it, or letting it
go, or destroying it.
It does all of that for
you, it's already written.
You can focus on what matters,
and that's the background work
and not how you get into or
out of your background task.
The trade-off here with
an IntentService instead
of another one, is that
an IntentService can only
handle one thing at a time.
All requests will
happen sequentially.
So if your app is designed
with multiple requests that
might come in and [INAUDIBLE]
at the exact same time,
you're going to have to read the
documentation on how services
work, sorry.
How do we create
an IntentService?
First step, you have to make
a class for your service.
And to do that you need to
declare it in your manifest.
You have to say that
this is going to be here.
Like, this actually exists
and I'm going to use it.
And then, of course,
some of you may know,
exported is this
variable that says
you can restrict
the service to only
being accessed by your app.
Which is what false means.
Or, if you say to
true, other apps
may be able to interact with
your service and set it off,
which is sometimes
really valuable.
You can also declare
multiple services.
You can have 13 of them and each
one is a very targeted service.
Definitely real service could
be like, definitely a real share
service, and like definitely
a real backup service,
and every one could have its
own specified task, which
makes code maintenance
really easy
and also means it's a lot
easier to track what's going on
and when things are going wrong.
But most importantly,
your service
needs to extend
from IntentService.
So, you have a class,
and the only method
you have to implement,
or override by default,
is on handle intent.
You can actually just
ignore all the other ones.
That's the whole lifecycle
being handled for you,
which is pretty fantastic.
So onHandleIntent, this
is where all of your work
is going to happen.
Imagine that.
So maybe this is
where you're going
to open a network connection,
or send data to your server,
and then clean up that
connection, that'd
be pretty great-- cleaning
up your network connections.
Or maybe you want to
write to the SD card.
All of this kind of
stuff is definitely not
supposed to effect your UI.
Maybe you'll send the message
updated and change something
to green.
But all of the data
you might need,
you can put into that
intent like as an extra,
pass it along, and then
use that to maybe kick off
a notification, or kick off
the work they need to do.
Anything that's really relevant,
services are pretty versatile.
Once you've got it written,
you need to invoke it.
And this happens from,
usually, an activity.
And to do that, you need
to create the intent,
fill it with something,
and then pass it.
And passing is great, you
just call startservice,
it's actually that easy.
OK, start it, I'm ready.
Like I said, like an
IntentService manages
it's own lifecycle.
You don't have to start
it, bind it, all the stuff.
You just call startservice with
the intent and you're done.
That's actually
all there is to it.
And then with all of
the data you pass along,
then your intent might--
your service might
be able to actually use that
same kind of intent to report
back.
So given enough information
to know what its job is
and if a response
is necessary, too.
You know that you can use
it calling startservice,
but the question is when
to call startservice,
and my advice is usually
from a BroadcastReceiver.
Because these are really great
ways of waiting for a signal
that something needs to happen.
Whenever anything
actually needs to happen.
So BroadcastReceiver job is
to respond to an announcement
and that comes in the form
of yet another intent.
These are magical
little things like,
I'd like to do this,
with these constraints.
So this is a common
trigger for kicking off
background work, which is great
because a BroadcastReceiver
doesn't actually bring your
app into the foreground.
It can kick off a
service that may
or not affect foreground work,
but the BroadcastReceiver
itself opens, runs on
receive, and triggers
whatever is in that, and then
stays all in the background.
So you're still protecting
your main thread,
which is our goal here.
So BroadcastReceiver
can actually
interact with several
different sources.
A local broadcast will come
from within your own app.
And this is a sign that maybe
it's time to sync, [INAUDIBLE]
the service, or
maybe it's actually
the IntentService reporting
back about how the job went,
or this failed, or
that's not a real URI.
App broadcasts can also
come from other apps
on the device, which is
really great when you're
trying to take advantage
of functionality
that you don't want to build,
but somebody else offers.
Or you want to
offer functionality
to other developers
so that you actually
get users using a lot of
different really great things.
So you don't have
to keep rebuilding
picture-taking every
time, or storage,
or something like that.
System broadcasts
are really important,
they carry status information.
Things like something
being plugged in,
or a signal that's changing.
So you might be subscribed to.
So if you really care
about your app only
runs when plugged in, because
maybe you're a sleep tracker
and you don't want
it to fall asleep
while the user's also asleep.
That's the kind of thing, you'd
wait for the signal on this,
and then if it came
unplugged, you'd
get a broadcast
that it's unplugged,
and that might
change your behavior.
You might only stop
tracking data to that point.
And finally, you can use
them for server messages,
like downstream messages.
GCM actually has its own
dedicated BroadcastReceiver
system, which I'll
tell you about.
Downstream messages
are a great way
for your server to indicate that
something needs to happen now.
Which the app might not be able
to give a signal on, right?
So basically BroadcastReceivers
are the best thing
ever because any kind of
message can come through,
and then you can react
accordingly, and maybe
start off any kind
of different service.
And just like service, you can
register multiple receivers.
So let's talk about
how to do that.
With an IntentService,
it's the same thing.
You have to create
the actual class,
and then declare it your
receiver in your manifest that
looks roughly the same.
But the meat of
everything here is
going to live in this
method called onreceive.
It's really the only
thing you have to override
with a BroadcastReceiver.
And this will do all of
your intent processing,
like you get the intent
that comes through,
and any extras might indicate
what kind of work you're doing
here, maybe your
BroadcastReceiver does double
duty, maybe it doesn't.
But this will help you do any
kind of processing and kicking
off your service.
The thing about a
BroadcastReceiver
is that it only lives
for the duration
of this onreceive call,
which is like milliseconds.
So, you can't do your core of
your background work in here.
You need to offload that to
prevent any further hanging.
Because otherwise as soon as
this call completes, it dies.
Also if you have
a helper method,
you don't really
have a chance here.
OK, so you also have to
register your BroadcastReceiver,
like you have to say which
intents you're interested in.
And we don't just
get everything,
that would be a nightmare.
Like just constant
information coming in.
And I recommend
looking into what's
called LocalBroadcastManager,
because if you're really
just using broadcast
within your own app,
as a signal to and from
services, this is a great tool.
You can also include
an intent filter,
like, I want this intent,
with these kinds of parameters
and stuff.
So it lets you set up everything
for a number of situations,
and I think it's pretty great.
So check the box on that.
Because we're going
to move on to what's
called a
WakefulBroadcastReceiver.
I told you that onreceive
only lasts, your app is only
brought to life for the
duration of onreceive which
means that there's a chance
that between onreceive
and startservice
like onreceive wraps
and your service
hasn't started yet,
there's a chance that the system
might take away your CPU time
inbetween that.
So if you need to guarantee
that your service runs
the moment that
onreceive ends, you
want to acquire a wake lock.
And you want to hold that wake
lock until your service has
a chance to run.
But wake locks are
hard, and you shouldn't
have to waste your time on
that, because we did it for you.
We created the
WakefulBroadcastReceiver,
which manages it's
own wake lock,
and still guarantee that your
service will run immediately
after onreceive.
So, again look at
all these things
we did for you, because
background work is really hard.
Let us manage as much
of the life-cycles
we can, unless you have some
sort of custom situation,
and at that point you're
already doing tons of research,
so you're golden, right?
OK, so implementing the
WakefulBroadcastReceiver
procedure, look it's exactly the
same, except I added the word
wakeful.
It's not scary all,
it's the only change.
It just means-- all these things
we worked really hard, finally
to make these great
tools for you,
because it wasn't
easy for so long.
OK so I mentioned that GCM
has its own special situation,
and I'd like to explain a
little bit more about that.
We really try to push
GCM, not just because we
love our own products,
but because if you
have to maintain a persistent
network connection on a device,
that's expensive.
It drains radio, it drains CPU
time, it drains the battery.
And so if every app is trying to
do their own homegrown version,
that's going to be horrible.
But if we can create one that
the entire device knows about,
that's smart enough to know
when to pass things along
to the right apps, and has
the right access things,
then we can save huge
performance wins,
huge user wins, and huge
developer effort, right?
And that's why you
can see us, we're
always pushing Google
Cloud Messaging.
The other thing is that
GCM has an advantage
that your homegrown
version will never have.
And that's that
all of our carriers
have worked with us to
give special recognition
to the ports that GCM
travels on, to keep
them open as long as possible.
Any messaging alternative you'll
see in downstream messaging,
will usually be
built on top of GCM,
or will be built on
a polling system.
And you don't-- if you don't
want to build your own polling
system, why would you want to
build on top of another one?
So throughout the conference,
as you see us all basically
force-feeding you
GCM, know that we have
a really good reason for it.
It's not just because we
happen to be cousins with it.
OK.
The other thing
about the GcmReceiver
is it actually extends from
WakefulBroadcastReceiver,
so you get that wake lock
management by default,
which is even better.
So to use it, you have
to declare your receiver
the way you would
any other receiver.
Except you have to
have something special,
which is the permission to send.
That means that
you are basically
adhering to the permission
required by GCM, because you
want you want protected
communications, so GCM
service requires
this permission,
and you honor this
permission, and that's
what this lets you to do,
to declare in your manifest.
And also, you set up an
intent filter to say like,
I want all receiving messages
from GCM to my application.
Super easy.
So then you build
your listener service.
Did you notice you don't
have to build a receiver?
You don't have to extend
from GCM receiver, that
already exists for you, you just
have to use it by declaring it.
Then all you have to do is
override your listener service.
It's not an intents service,
but it's still pretty great
because you don't have to
manage and life-cycles still.
Then your message comes
in with who it's from,
so you get your server ID.
You can double check
that you're getting it
from the right
messaging case, maybe
you have multiple
different things.
And you get all
the information you
need in data based on how you
structure your own data when
you send it.
So great, so great, why
are you not doing this?
So now we can move on from how
background work specifically
like how to implement it,
to when to implement it,
and how to invoke it.
You know you can
call startservice,
but the question is,
what do you really
use to trigger a reminder
when it comes later?
And when does it
need to come later?
So concerning that
question of when,
if you need your work to run
at a specific moment in time,
you're going to get to
meet the AlarmManager.
So an alarm is not
like a wake up alarm,
like, 'ding, ding, ding'
alarm is a signal to your app
that it's time for your app to
wake up and do some more work.
And when you register
an intent with an alarm,
it'll actually fire that
intent as soon as it
fires through the AlarmManager.
So setting alarms
with AlarmManager.
To set a single alarm with
anything that's above API 19
you can call set.
Look how simple that is.
And it sets a single
inexact alarm.
And what inexact means
is that, let's say
your alarm is supposed
to go off in an hour,
it will not go off
before that hour,
but it may go off
sometime after that hour,
if the system is
trying to intelligently
batch things together.
Because we want to save
battery as much as possible,
so if we know there
are four alarms coming
up sometime between
three and four,
we might try to run them
all at the same time.
But it will never fire early
and that's a guarantee.
We also have setwindow,
which is if you're flexible,
and you don't really
mind using set,
but you want to have a
definite duration of time,
this is pretty great,.
Because you can specify what
that window is going to be.
And then when it
really does matter,
we have setexact, in order
to specify that time actually
really does matter.
And this is important for
maybe a calendar reminder.
If you're 40 minutes
late on that,
you've actually really messed
up with your users' life.
The other thing to
note is that any API
before 19 set and setexact
are equivalent because we
didn't actually intoduce an
exact timing until KitKat.
So API before 19, you
would just call set.
And it's already exact,
how great is that?
So to do this, look
how few lines of code
this is, like this
isn't terrifying.
You don't have to worry.
You just get the AlarmManager
service from the system,
create your intent, and you
have to turn your intent
into a pending intent.
And that's how the AlarmManager
is able to actually fire it.
Definitely use
request codes here.
So I'm skipping-- you
could call a receiver here,
that would make a lot of sense,
because maybe you want to react
to a different kind of thing.
I'm skipping straight
to the service,
I know that this alarm means
it's time to run this thing.
I'm going to invoke
that service directly.
And then I set it up for
whenever I want it to,
time to trigger.
I didn't declare that
because I don't know on here,
maybe I want it to be an hour.
Different situation-- maybe
you don't want a single alarm,
maybe you want an alarm
that repeats itself
on its own schedule.
This is, surprisingly,
still AlarmManager.
You're not surprised,
it's not a surprise.
So with repeating alarms,
we have setInexactRepeating
for guess what?
InexactRepeating alarms.
So you specify a period
of time, like maybe
you need it to go
off every hour,
but not necessarily on the hour.
You have a little
bit of give there.
So we'll go off every hour, but
maybe, maybe at 15, maybe not.
Which is pretty
fantastic as far as like,
I need this to be
done fairly regularly,
but I don't specifically
care that it's at 4:02pm.
Then that means that you can
talk about set exact repeating,
except it doesn't exist.
That's not a thing,
we didn't create that,
because it doesn't make
a whole lot of sense.
We actually say, use setexact,
to set a repeating alarm,
and then when it triggers
that one, set the next one.
Because if it's that exact, you
probably have something else
you care about, and you
probably want to check on that.
The other truth is we
actually don't really
recommend this either,
we would rather you just
not set exact repeating
alarms at all.
So setting and exact repeating
is really your answer,
but if you need a special use
case, just do it one at a time
and build that into how
you manage your alarm.
So to set an
InexactRepeating alarm,
you see how it's pretty much
exactly the same, as far as
setting it up.
And then you call
InexactRepeating,
but instead of just
saying the time trigger,
you have to add that interval,
an interval that you really
care about.
Again, I just made up a variable
because I don't specifically
care about counting out
milliseconds, right now.
Now what if you need your
alarm to go off often?
Let's say every
60 seconds, right?
Like it's something that
triggers another action,
maybe you're
checking on a censor,
or there's something
that you need to do
incredibly, incredibly, often.
We don't recommend
AlarmManager at all.
We think you should
write your own handler
to handle this kind of thing
and use a time trigger.
But I'm not going to
teach you how to do that,
because that's really bad
for performance and battery.
And you should probably try to
find an alternative instead.
But you should know
that it exists.
Now when your job needs to
go off at some point today,
maybe-ish, like, just
whenever we're on Wi-Fi,
like either when you
don't really care,
you just want it
to happen, or when
you're waiting for a specific
set of conditions to be met.
This is when you're going to get
to that wonderful thing that's
called JobScheduler And
you're not afraid, right,
because you have
all this background
and not intimidated anymore.
So JobScheduler
isn't complicated,
it's just got a lot
of pieces to it.
So let's talk about background.
It was introduced in
Lollipop, and what it does, is
it doesn't work off of a time
schedule the way an alarm does,
instead it works based
off of conditions.
Maybe I'm waiting for Wi-Fi
when the user isn't actually
using their phone.
That's a pretty good time to
run an upload of photos, right?
JobScheduler is designed
to make it really
easy for the system to batch
jobs, because everybody says,
I have this job
it needs to happen
at this kind of situation,
and I have one, too.
And you're like, oh great, you
both want Wi-Fi, Wi-Fi is on,
let's go together.
Like hold hands,
you got a buddy.
And that's our
battery and perf win,
which will make
[INAUDIBLE] really happy.
The other thing is
JobScheduler surprisingly runs
on the main thread.
And I'm not really kidding, like
the job service that you create
will run on your main thread.
So when you're actually
doing complicated work,
you use your job
service in conjunction
with some other
background service,
like a task, a basic task,
or like an intent service.
So to use
JobScheduler, you start
by creating that
job service that
runs on the main thread,
which is very odd in my mind.
To do this, you need to
override at least two methods,
if not more.
The first is onstart
job, which is called,
not by you, but by
the system, when
it's time to start your job.
But because it runs
on the main thread,
this is the place where you want
to kick off to your other work
when you're doing
heavy computations.
If you're just setting
a job to maybe send
a notification because it's
six o'clock, that's fine.
But anything that's heavy,
you want to kick it off here.
And when you
override onstart job,
in addition to
starting web work here,
you need to return a Boolean.
So you're going to return
true if you've moved work
to a background thread, in order
to perform that kind of stuff
to show that something
else is going on
and JobScheduler needs
to be aware of that.
But you return false
if it was a simple task
and you've already finished
and we're done processing.
So that's what
that Boolean means.
And then for onstop
job, you actually,
this is called by
the system again,
but it's only when the job
is cancelled before it gets
the chance to be finished.
So maybe you were waiting for
Wi-Fi, and then you had it,
but the user left
the Wi-Fi zone,
and now you don't
have it anymore.
You haven't finished.
So we cancel the job,
because these conditions
aren't being met anymore.
And so this is what
this Boolean is for,
whatever cleanup you
need to do is important.
But also you need to
return true if you
want to reschedule that job
because it didn't have a chance
to run.
But if it didn't really matter,
then you can return false,
and it will just be dropped.
So that's what those super
indicative Booleans are.
And then that third method
that you don't override,
but you need to call that
lives inside job services
is jobFinished And this
is how you call it,
you need to in your service,
way away, they've kicked off to,
once you're done with
your work, you call this,
and you pass back the job
parameters that were passed in.
You see?
From here, your onstop job?
So I put them in, but you need
to pass these parameters back
to indicate which jobs
we're finished with.
And this tells the system
that we actually completed,
we're good, we're very,
very happy, and we're done
and you don't have to
worry about rescheduling.
Unless you failed at your job.
Maybe like the
network connection
fell through or something
on your server's end.
So that's what that
Boolean here means.
True means we need to
reschedule the job,
and false means that we're good.
And when we're rescheduling
true will kick off.
JobScheduler has a built in
exponential back off for you.
You don't have to
do that math, you
don't have to keep track
of when you want to retry.
We'll do that intelligently
on your behalf.
We just know that
you didn't succeed,
and you want to try again,
and so we'll reschedule you.
Look how helpful we are.
I have talked about "we"
like I didn't work on this,
I know how to use it.
You need to register
your service, as usual,
but you also need to
bind to the job service.
And so yet another
permission that's
nested in with our declaration.
And finally you
create the scheduler.
So this is going to be
probably in an activity
where you're keeping
track of everything.
And there's a couple
of pieces here.
So second bit of this
is the JobScheduler
we're just fetching that
from the system again.
Very easy.
And then we create
a JobInfo object,
and that needs some
sort of ID for the jobs
that your activity
knows what's going on.
But also, the name
of the service.
So for the first time, we're
not using an intent to rely on,
we're just using the class name.
Which we get from the
component name class.
And then all the
conditions you care about,
and I'll touch on
that in just a minute.
And then you just call
scheduler, schedule.
With your JobInfo
Very, very easy.
So the hard part
is with JobInfo,
and these are just some of
the offers JobInfo offers.
I told you, you could
decide you only care
about certain
criteria, and this is
where you can set all
of those criteria, when
you're worried about your job.
A couple of these
are pretty obvious,
like you can create your own
back off and retry policy,
and that'll be used when we're
rescheduling your job for you.
You can create a minimum
delay before your job is run.
So if you say I want to do
this whenever Wi-Fi is on,
but I don't want to do it until
at least six hours from now.
That can be really helpful,
especially if you're managing
traffic with your server.
We have an override
deadline, so that's
the maximum amount of
time that could pass
before your job must be run.
That's really
helpful, too, if you
know that you have to
get something done today,
and it's going to hit
midnight or whatever.
Persistent indicates that
you want to persist this job
request across a reboot.
A lot of times when your app
is started for the first time,
then you might
change your behavior,
but if you know that you
need this after the reboot,
that's a great way
to indicate it.
Then we have connectivity
requirements.
It could be you're waiting for
any network, metered or not.
Or maybe you're just waiting
for Wi-Fi specifically.
You've got some constants
in the class that
will help you specify that.
And of course
charging, and/or idle.
Idle indicating that the
screen is off, usually.
This is the magic
of JobScheduler.
This is like where
it really happens.
And then we have this
hypothetical situation
of do I just use one?
And I would say, no.
So what if you have a situation
where a user presses a share
button, that stops
your IntentService
because a share probably needs
to happen right away that's
user initiated.
But you're not actually online
for some reason, maybe it's
a bad connection, or maybe
you can't really [INAUDIBLE].
So you could then use
your IntentService
to schedule a job schedule, like
a job service for you, right?
And then that way you
don't have to worry, again,
about keeping track
of your own back off
or your own retry you don't have
to worry about what's going on.
You can just be
like, OK I failed
when I tried to
do it immediately,
the user probably wont
notice since they're not
on the internet anyway.
So just schedule this for later.
And this is one of
those things that
are-- it's hard to teach, how
do you teach someone to consider
multiple different
resources to build
the best possible behavior?
This is one that I was
talking about my talk,
and Ian was like,
well, you know,
you should tell them
about like fun things.
Well I didn't even
think of that.
How do I stand up here and
teach people if I can't even
think of all these things?
And so it is hard, and
that's why I really
like when people share
about [INAUDIBLE].
Because this would be a
great situation and it
makes things so much
easier for the developer.
You can use these
kinds of services,
not just take work
off the main thread,
but also to make it
so you don't have
to build your own logic
that's been built 17,000 times
already.
OK, so trying to teach you
how to build better apps,
and also how to
not work very hard.
This is going to be really
successful, you guys.
The final point I
want to touch on
is what about the actual alarms?
Like those ones that
go "ding, ding, ding"
and wake you up from your nap.
If AlarmManager manages
the other alarms,
how do you actually
schedule these?
Those seem really
important, do I
have to issue my own
sound notification
or something, every time
my AlarmManager goes off?
The thing is, no, you don't.
Because AlarmManager has this
super helpful set alarm clock
method.
And then of course, you can
get the next alarm clock.
But that's introduced
in 21, clearly,
since I wrote that on the thing.
So what's special about these
methods is they were introduced
relatively recently.
And also these are exempt
from any kind of doze mode,
or standby, idle mode
that we've introduced.
Because alarm clocks are
incredibly important.
The user probably
relies on those
for getting to work on time.
And so what's really
cool about setalarmclock
is that if you set that
alarm, let's say for like 6:30
in the morning, and
you're in doze mode
because you've had to charge
your phone over night.
Those mode will exit
well before 6:30
to give every app a
chance to run and sync,
so when the user finally
hears that noise and wakes up
and checks their
phone, everything's
ready-- the news
is already there.
So I think that that's a
really cool build around.
So you can definitely
rely on these.
If you're using, if
you're not quite to 21,
but you're on KitKat, you
can just call setupexact
because we're not
worried about doze
because you're on
an older phone.
But you know exactly
that this time
is going to happen because
setexact will be on it.
And then finally,
for before KitKat,
you can just use set
directly because we
didn't introduce inexact
timing until after that.
And so that's how you would
cover actual important alarms.
And that's my whole talk.
Other things you probably
want to look into
are sync adapters, which
will help you manage data
programmatically on your own.
And also we have GCM's
networks manager.
So if you want to
look at something
similar to JobScheduler, but
is a little bit more targeted,
you should read
that documentation.
But hey, now you're all
JobScheduler pros, right?
You could totally do
this on your own, right?
Right?
That's not very enthusiastic.
Thank you, Alex!
OK, cool.
This is how you can find me on
Google+ and on Twitter if you
have any questions always
feel free to call me.
I will honestly try
to respond to them.
I'm bad at social networking,
but I'm working on it.
And I will be
mingling in this room
if you have any other
questions about how to do this.
But hopefully you're not scared
of background jobs and services
the way I was last year.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]